your turn you ready let's make some
bacon bud
you will kill
[Music]
the german halberd
[Music]
used by swiss armies during the medieval
era the halberd was a versatile lethal
weapon of war
a combination of spike hook and axe it
was a triple threat foot soldiers would
defend themselves against knights on
horseback by using its back hook to
catch and dismount their opponents and
then move in for the kill using the
spear point to thrust or the axe to
slice through armor an infamous killer
king charles the bold the duke burgundy
met his fate when his head was halfed by
a halberd ending the burgundian wars in
1477.
[Music]
to see what kind of lethal damage your
halberd will do
we'll take your hull bird and deliver
thrust hacks and attempt to dismount
that dummy with its hook fill your purse
you ready for this yes sir
[Music]
[Music]
all right phil your spear tip is sharp
not only at the point but its edges also
your accent not only did it dig in and
break the ribs it went in and cut the
internal organs that were behind the
ribs and the hook blade it dug into the
ribs and dismounted the dummy from the
horse overall
your weapon here
will kill thank you good job all right
jonathan you're up next you ready let's
do it my halberd's a brute i'm excited
to hear doug tell me it'll kill that'll
make my son happy i want to see some
blood and gordon guts
[Music]
all right jonathan on the thrust your
spear tip right here penetrated deep and
created a deep wound channel
your accent here
pretty much it was just the tip that
penetrated into the chest and also into
the diaphragm your hook broke the ribs
got into the organs and dismounted the
whole dummy from the horse the most
important thing about this whole thing
is
it will kill
all right bladesmiths next up is a
strength test
ben
[Music]
to test the strength and durability of
your hull birds i'll be chopping into
this corrugated sheet steel remember
this test is all about what the steel
does to your hubbards and not what your
halberds do to the steel filler up first
you ready yes sir
[Music]
well phil your hubbard held up perfectly
all of the faces on it are still razor
sharp there's no deformation that i can
see
overall very well done thank you
jonathan you're up you ready
[Music]
well jonathan on the hits your edges
held up pretty well i don't see any
problems with them the one thing that
does concern me is the blade's taking a
bit of a bend to one side here but the
edges and the points seem to have done
pretty well in the penetration the whole
thing held up still solid well done
up next is the sharpness test and for
that i give you to dave
all right bladesmiths to test the
sharpness of your blades i'll be cutting
through these fish using both the blade
and the tip of your halberds now a good
sharp blade should cut through those
fish nice and clean
phil you ready go for it
[Music]
[Music]
all right
the cuts look very clean they're just
nice slices
i really like the design of this weapon
the handle feels good it's got some heft
to it but it's balanced nicely but most
off it's definitely a sharp weapon we
built the cutter good job thank you sir
jonathan you ready always
phil's blade performed pretty good in
the fish test i didn't know we're gonna
cut fish with it i'm sweating the
geometry
all right jonathan you went with
actually trying to forge this all out of
one piece which i appreciate it's just
there's still a lot of that weight here
the socket's very very thick it's
covered but you can feel the edge of it
the shape you see that historically
quite a bit but for this test it's a
little harder to find the sweet spot on
that shape with that tip being knocked
out of alignment a little bit harder to
target harder to index but it's a good
cutter nicely done
phil jonathan you've both done some
amazing work on your german halberds and
they perform very well in our weapons
tests however in this arena of
competition only the best weapon can win
and our next forest and fire champion is
phil
congratulations you are a new fortune
fire champion jonathan unfortunately
your weapon did not make the cut please
surrender your weapon
phil congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job it's all the
hard work worth it the hard work was
worth it i'm very pleased to have been
here it was wonderful well phil
please present your weapon to the judges
with pleasure
philip baldwin won and phil baldwin
feels very good about winning
i would not have missed the experience
of appearing on forage and fire for
anything in the world i met some really
fine people i would have never met in
any other circumstances
and i really thank my fellow competitors
for being here
the german longsword
[Music]
the german longsword traces its roots
back to 14th century europe this
two-handed weapon was powerful enough to
deliver deadly blows and its
double-edged blade inflict deep wounds
and slashes against any enemy that came
across its path
the massive blade was so powerful that
skilled warriors had to train
extensively in the art of long sword
fencing to master its strength
while this weapon was no longer used in
combat longsword fencing is practiced
around the world today
young fortune fire champions welcome to
the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your german longswords will do i'm going
to take your weapon and deliver some
lethal blows on this pig carcass
container first ready for this do it
all right colton let's talk about your
german long sword
every slice was a very deep slice
overall the balance the feel of your
sword
you will keel
kevin your turn are you ready you know
it
all right kevin those are very deep cuts
almost got through the pick of the first
strike now earlier prior to this you had
a little bend at the tip but it didn't
get any worse overall your weapon sir
you will kill thank you very much
doug almost went through my pig on the
first slice i was really kind of
yeah but it was not quite enough to
distract him from the warp in the sword
so he did end up noticing that and you
know that could be what sends me home
blitzmas welcome to the strength test
the throne chop
in order to test the strength of your
edge as well as the overall construction
of your german longswords i'll be
bashing them into this throne colton
you're up first you're ready for this
let's do it all right
[Music]
all right colton this is uh
it's a great looking blade man i like
your damascus pattern uh it's still
nice and straight didn't take much
damage beyond a slight clinton so well
done thank you
all right kevin you're up man you ready
you know it all right
all right kevin well your sword is all
in one piece
again the slightest of glinting on the
edge from contact with the wood but
nothing i would call damage
you had a slight warp to it coming in
that hasn't changed it's the same all in
all you know i think you did a good job
on your grinds the weight is good and it
held up great from the strength there
nice job thank you very much
all right young guns this is the
sharpness test the cowhide bag slice
call new york first you ready for this
let's do it let's do this
[Music]
all right colton
your edge
cuts cleanly it's razor sharp in
thrusting drawing it back and cutting
the balance is good
and overall sir
it will cut thank you
kevin your turn you ready you know it
let's do this
all right kevin your edge
razor sharp it cut cleanly all through
the bags and overall your weapon
you'll hot thank you
placements throughout this competition
you both have amazed us tremendously but
as you know only one of you can go home
with the win the judges have talked it
over and they made a final decision
the bladesmith going home with a check
for ten thousand dollars and his second
fortune fire champion title is
colton congratulations
kevin you fought hard and you brought us
a beautiful blade but unfortunately your
time this competition has ended i'm
gonna have to ask you to please step off
the fourth floor
peace
it turns out that i am not gonna be the
uh two-time youngest champion but
losing to colton he's an amazing smith
does amazing work and i'm glad it was
him and not somebody else
well colton that means you are the
youngest two-time fortune fire champion
and you got yourself another check for
ten thousand dollars congratulations
being the youngest two-time fortune fire
champion feels amazing i mean this is
probably one of the closest competitions
that i have seen
and um to come out on top it it just
feels great
really really well done
my name is colton arias and i'm the
youngest two-time forge and fire
champion
this is by-hander
the zveyhander which means two-hander in
german was a massive sword wielded by
swiss and german mercenary armies in the
16th century sometimes stretching over
six feet in length this by-hander was a
long sword featuring an extended grip
and broad garden
as european armies employed more pikes
and pole arms on the battlefield the
zvey hender emerged as a counter weapon
this enormous sword was used to break up
pike formations by cutting spear ends
and opening up holes in enemy lines due
to its size this by-hander was only
wielded by the biggest and most
audacious soldiers if these soldiers
survived charges into enemy spears they
would often be paid double for their
substantial risk the zveyhander
eventually faded from the battlefield
but survives today in games such as dark
souls your spy handers are big so we
came to a big open space to test them up
first the sharpness test dave
now the survival handler was known as a
weapon of intimidation
to test the sharpness of your edge i'm
going to cut into this bundle of sugar
cane twice once with either side
jay you're up first here ready
ready as i'm ever gonna be
it's got a lot of weight to it
but
obviously it's plenty sharp
nicely done thank you all right stephen
you're up are you ready can't wait jay's
weapon did really well cutting through
the sugar canes i'm not nervous about
mine but you know i don't know if it's
gonna cut better than his his cut real
strong
[Music]
it's light it's easy to wheel
that guard it's almost where it's
into you when you're swinging it
you can see it cut deep and clean it
looks like the blade held up beautifully
so nice job thank you
bladesmiths the zyhander was a weapon of
war big weapon big damage i will take
your weapon and deliver killing blows on
this ballistic dummy let's see how much
damage your weapon can do
jay you're up first you ready go for it
let's do this
it is a heavy weight and it's harder to
manipulate with multiple blows
but on the thrust i was able to go in
one side and all the way
on the opposite side of the dummy
this sir
will kill
thank you
steven you're up next you ready
absolutely let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
that's brutal
okay steve
the edge of your sword
is sharp enough to last weight all the
way into the ribs and on the power
strike
that would disembowel
and ruin this person
that's the idea
this sword
will kill
good job thank you
gentlemen this is the strength test now
this vyandra was often used against pike
formations so i'm going to take yours by
handers and go against a rack of pikes
here five times with each of your blades
see how far i can break through
jay you're up are you ready ready
so after two tests stephen and i are
pretty neck and neck so i feel pretty
nervous because this next test should
really determine who's gonna take home
the prize
wow
when you start swinging this thing it
moves things out of its way
i don't see any damage to your edge
nicely done thank you
all right steve you're up
do it okay
obviously it's a good cutter to actually
bend into that wood and split that
right down the middle
very easy to wield because of its light
weight
but i think we've
bent just a little bit
it's bent in two directions
and there is a crack now developing in
the handle
gentlemen we've got a lot to discuss
we'll see you back at the forge
i'm concerned i had a warp in my blade
so i don't know who's gonna end up with
the win
bladesmiths the judges have made their
final decision it's time to declare one
of you the forged and fire champion
jay
congratulations
steven unfortunately your sword did not
make the cut please surrender your
weapon
i'm disappointed
i really wanted to win uh but that's
okay i love being at the forge it's hot
it's dirty you'll smell funny but it is
so rewarding
jay congratulations you are the forest
and fire champion good job
thank
you how you feel right now oh i feel
like my heart's about to burst out of my
chest but well it's the heaviest weapon
i've ever had to wield in this
competition very well balanced and a
powerful weapon too thank you in the way
you built your handle that tells me a
lot about the way that you make things
the wood is fitted on and then wrapped
with leather with these reinforcing
pieces underneath that's the proper way
to construct it oh thank you
well jay
in exchange for that sword and those
socks
and we'll be receiving that check for
ten thousand dollars
when they announced that i was the
winner it felt really good had people
tell me you know you're good at what you
do but i always have this kind of
self-doubt
to make it all the way to the end and be
the champion i'm so happy
the lynch next sword
[Music]
created by emperor maximilian the first
in the 15th century the lance connects
were a deadly mercenary force armed with
pikes swords and crossbows
the most battle proven lance connect
mercenaries were armed with massive
two-handed swords
these imposing blades featured parrying
lugs above the guard to deflect enemy
attacks
earning double the pay of their peers
these garishly dressed swordsmen of
fortune would rush headlong into enemy
pikes in an effort to disrupt their
opponent's formations
today you can see the landschneck sword
and the hit mobile strategy game
dominations bladesmiths the two-handed
german lag tech swords a big sword so
we're expecting big damage i will take
your sword and deliver slashes thrust
and chops on this wild boar carcass
tidy up first you ready yes i am let's
do this
uh
[Music]
all right todd first up your handle
construction it's comfortable to hold on
to
you have a very thick and wide and stout
edge so it's a chopper not a slicer the
big issue i have with this is that it's
a heavy sword
but despite its weight
it will kill
all right dj it's your turn you ready
yep
[Music]
dj is talking about your sword here
it's even heavier than the other side
the tip you have over here is wide the
first thrust went in the second one
couldn't and i tried
the one thing it did was break its back
a thrust like that in a broken back like
that
we'll kill
all right
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test to test the overall
construction of your blade i'll be both
stabbing and chopping into the steel
plate
all right todd you're up first you ready
yes
[Music]
and then
all right todd you took some pretty good
rolls
these rolls are fairly deep
but uh hello
nice and done
all right dj you ready for this
yep
oh board
all right dj and this weapon is
heavy
look at that balance point so far
forward keeping that tip up
is brutal
you've got a really really super stout
edge and
honestly it held up quite well there's
some rolls here where it connected but
uh the weapon's
still solid
it's a strong blade
thank you
all right gentlemen your blades are
still in one piece now let's see if they
still have an edge to test that edge
i'll be cutting through this cane
todd you're up you ready
yes okay
hear that it sings it's like a tuning
fork
all right todd so let's talk about your
uh singing sword here
you definitely have a sharp edge here
sharp sword made good cuts hold on thank
you thank you
all right dj you ready
are you ready it's a big one
[Laughter]
i'm ready
i can
run my finger
along that edge
on the first cut as soon as i hit the
dull part it just starts pushing stuff
over
did a good job putting it together
but uh it's just not sharp enough to cut
todd dj you've both done an incredible
amount of work to bring these massive
swords back for our final round of
competition but there can only be one
forged and fire champion that champion
is
todd
congratulations you are the new forest
and fire champion
dj unfortunately your sword didn't make
the cut please surrender your blade
my biggest regret is i should have spent
more time on the edge
i did my best and i didn't want to build
something that was going to snap and i
definitely did that
todd congratulations you are the new
forged and fire champion and that is a
title that comes with a check
10 000 good job thank you
thank you
please present your blade to the judges
i'm a little surprised you know it's
still like a surreal kind of thing i've
proven what i've come to prove that i'm
capable that i'm still skilled and i'm
thrilled that i was up to the challenge
i feel so good i don't know how to feel
the messer
and by knife
it gonna be a challenge
the messer which translates to knife in
german was an imposing 15th century
sword classification these weapons
ranged in size from single-handed
thrusting knives that were ideal for
stabbing to two-handed killers designed
to brutally slash and destroy enemies
with a single blow its most
distinguishing characteristic is its
long hilt often secured with rivets
that was not only aesthetic but
protected the hand and knuckles from
attacks
extremely versatile the blade's thick
slightly curved profile in large clip
point were popular with both soldiers on
the battlefield and noblemen for hunting
game
complementing the messer german hunters
also carried a small utility by knife
for skinning and eating after the hunt
this is the pig carcass slice and dice
i will take your weapon to deliver
killing blows on this big carcass
john your first you ready for this let's
make some bacon bud
oh
yeah yes
all right john your messer is sharp
it's a little bit forward heavy but the
weight lends itself to chop the pig in
half now your by knife razor sharp those
cuts alone were cutting deeply with
every move and overall sir it will kill
oh yes
all right jeff your turn you ready yes
sir
uh all right jeff your messer
beautiful balance it's not forward heavy
it actually is something i can wield
forward same balance on the recovery
when i'm pulling back to cut now your by
knife the edge is razor sharp with every
cut and stab that it does overalls are
your weapons
they will kill thanks sir
all right gentlemen now to test the
strength and durability of your blades
i'll be chopping into our log here
now remember this is not about what your
messers are going to do that log or what
that log might do to your messers and
then i'm going to take your by knives
and we're going to do a tip test by
driving that tip of your blade into that
log all right john you're up you ready
do your worst okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right john well let's start with
your messenger your edge is still sharp
blade's still straight true your blade's
got a lot of weight to it your handle
is a little confusing when you're
swinging this having that bead right
there my hand kind of wants to go all
the way up to the guard and having this
the well further back sort of pushes my
hand a little bit back behind where i'd
like it to be as far as your by knife
goes not a mark on it really well done
thank you sir all right jeff
your turn you ready yes sir okay
there's a chance that my weapon is going
to break and a weapon break is one of
the last things that you want to have
happen
if there's one thing that i can pick
that i wouldn't want him to do it's to
hammer my knife in and then bend it on
the tip so
my heart is in my throat
all right let's start with your messer
what i really like about this blade
is the way you balanced it puts all that
weight right back in my hand where i
want it your knife
it's a really pretty piece it's very
comfortable in the hand but um
just a little brittle on the tip
but they are both beautiful pieces
nicely done thanks sir
[Music]
all right bladesmiths the rope slice
surprise
[Music]
now unlike the strength this is all
about what your edge will do to
different materials we have out here
john you're up first you ready for this
please do sir do this
[Music]
all right john we're in the first cup
with your buy knife it's a light knife
it didn't cut all the way through it's
starting to unravel and of course your
messer finish that off
on these tubes
this cut cleanly all the way through
your weapon sir
we'll cut
thank you
all right jeff it's your turn you ready
sir yes sir going into the sharpness
test
if my blades don't
outperform john's it's you know it's
over
all right jeff first up your buy knife
despite the fact that just the tip broke
off the edge is razor sharp and one cut
is cut cleanly through the rope you're a
messer once again the balance just feels
so good in the hand it's such an easy
weapon to wield and slice
overall sir your weapons
will cut
thank you sir
blade smith's the judge's deliberation
is complete they've made their final
decision
our new fortune fire champion is
[Music]
jeff congratulations you're the new
foreign fire champion john unfortunately
your blades did not make the cut please
surrender your blades
somebody has to win and i wish it could
have been me
but i honestly feel the judges made the
right decision
jeff's messer was a work of art and he
deserved to win
jeff congratulations you're the new
forrester fire chairman and that's the
title comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars how do you feel right
now
validated sir please present your blades
to the judges
i'm happy um i can't even describe my
emotions right now
ford's and fire champion baby bringing
it back to kentucky hell yeah
yes
the boar sword
specifically designed for the hunt the
boar sword originated from 16th century
germany featuring a long reinforced
blade with a spear lake head this weapon
was built to both thrust and withstand
the power of a charging boar the weapon
also contained a cross piece built into
the blade that functioned as a guard to
stop the animal from sliding down the
weapon and injuring the user given its
highly specific nature boar swords were
never used extensively by the public or
by militaries but were the favorite
hunting weapon of the founder of the
land schneck mercenaries and patriarch
of the habsburg dynasty 16th century
holy roman emperor maximilian
all right bladesmiths to test the
lethality of your bore swords i will
deliver thrusts and cuts on this boar
carcass
john you're first you ready for this
absolutely good luck
thanks man
i can't wait to see what my sword does
to that board i want to see whether or
not it will kill
[Music]
all right john first up i like the
balance
i like that i can put two hands in it
it's all void enough to where i can hold
on and i can tell where the edge is and
when we're pushing and thrusting as it's
meant to be
the tip is sharp enough to thrust all
the way through your edges as you can
see
are sharp enough to cut pieces out of
this poor carcass overall sir
it'll kill
thanks sir congrats
thanks man
all right isaac your turn are you ready
for this let's make some bacon
[Music]
all right
first up it's much lighter
so it's easier to control when you're
moving with the blade and as you can see
when i was thrusting in there the point
you have here the edges are very sharp
it thrusts all the way in and even when
it hits bone
it's got a very good flex to it do not
pick up again
overall sir
your boar sword
will make bacon and keel
thank you
gentlemen it's time for the strength
test the sheet metal stab
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i'll be
stabbing into the sheet metal but this
test is not about what your blades do to
that target it's about what that target
does to your blades jonathan you're here
first you ready absolutely
[Music]
all right jonathan
your blade is still sharp pretty much
all the way to the tip now the tip did
get flattened a little bit but that was
a very very acute tip that you had on
there all in all it's a comfortable
weapon
it's certainly held up beautifully
nice done thank you
all right isaac are you ready for this
as ready as i'm gonna be
[Music]
there's definitely a significant bend
all right there's a good flex in your
blade which we saw in an earlier test
but when you quench this blade i'm
assuming right in here somewhere was
where that quench stopped
so
this is not really solid right here
you did lose your tip up here but your
edges held up
it's still sharp but you can just see
there's an obvious
issue with that bend there
all right bladesmiths this is the
sharpness test
to find out if there's any sharpness
left on your tip and edges i will take
your weapon and stab and slash at this
deer hide now unlike the strength test
this is all about what your blade will
do to this deer height john you're first
you ready for this let's do it
[Music]
all right john
looking at the tip here i can see where
it flattened out took a little bit of
effort to be able to puncture through
but it did
your edges are still sharp the cuts are
clean
overall sir
you have a cut thanks sir all right how
you suck your turn sir are you ready i
am
[Music]
so about what i expected
i straightened it
oh did you
the damage to your tip on the strength
that's really took it out there is no
tip to this anymore i can put my finger
on that but the edge of your blade on
both sides as you can see cut all the
way through
now the interesting thing to note is
that all that bending actually
straightened your blade
overall sir
bit of a cut
thank you
bladesmiths the judges have deliberated
right here on the forge floor they've
made their final decision
isaac your blade didn't make the cut
your blade took a bend in the strength
test and for that reason i have to ask
you to please leave a forge
well jonathan it would appear that
warrior ethos runs deep in you because
not only are you an active duty marine
you are also the forged and fire
champion that's a title that comes with
a check for ten thousand dollars
congratulations
being fortune fired champion it feels
great
it's a boost of confidence it's not the
big things that really matter it's the
little things the attention to detail
that make a big difference
[Applause]
the dousage
yes
dating back to the 16th century the
dousage began as a military sidearm for
german troops mimicking the blade of a
saber combined with the hilt of a
broadsword its curved design delivered
deadly hacks and slices while its basket
hilt provided protection in close
quarters combat
featuring a wide single-edged blade its
double-sided fuller kept it light for
quick maneuvering similar to the cutlass
this sword was favored by pirates and
naval officers because they were easy to
conceal and quick to draw this
intimidating sword can be seen in the
2016 tv series black sails
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
the european will do i'll take your
weapon deliver some slashes of thrust on
this big carcass scott you're up first
you ready for this oh yeah let's do this
[Music]
oh
all right scott first up it is light the
balance really allows for velocity and
recovery with this blade and most
importantly
it will kill
yeah
all right mark your turn so you ready
heck yeah let's do this
you're just hanging there like chewing
gum
all right mark talk about your bleed
here it's beautiful in its creation the
edge is sharp i was quite amazed with
the cuts i was surprised that it cut
that deeply the one thing though is that
that guard right there there rubs on my
knuckle
not bad but it does rub on the knuckle
despite that it will kill yes
[Music]
all right gentlemen
welcome to the strength test the whiskey
barrel chop
yeah now to test the strength and
overall construction of your swords i
will be swinging into these whiskey
barrels scott you're up first you ready
for this oh yeah all right
first off scott this thing is still
a razor blade on its entire length
except for right there you did take a
bit of a roll there and a very small
chip but beautiful craftsmanship super
light fast blade and very strong nicely
done thank you
mark you're up next are you ready for
this smash them okay
here she goes
all right mark got an edge all the way
across this thing you didn't lose a bit
the only issue i have with this weapon
at all is doug said my knuckle
rides right there on the inside of the
guard it's not chewing my hand up but
there is contact right there where i
don't necessarily want it it's a
beautiful weapon it's strong nicely done
thank you
all right bladesmith this is the
sharpness test the four pillars slice
these pillars are wrapped in different
materials foam leather canvas and silk
it's got hair first ready for this oh
yeah
[Music]
all right scott's talking about your
weapon here it is light every cut it
cuts nicely overall sir
it will cut thank you all right mark on
to your shiny sword you ready for this
slice and dice
so
all right mark's talking about your
blade here
that's a cutter right there you can feel
the weight and the power with your
slashes with this on the leather it did
cut
it's just because thicker kind of blade
that you have here to cut all the way
through but overall sir
you'll cut
nice
mark scott both of you guys turned in
incredibly competitive blades however
the judges have completed their
deliberation they've made their final
decision our new forged and fire
champion is
scott congratulations
mark unfortunately the judges have
decided that your blade doesn't make the
cut please surrender your blade
that was a fine piece man going home
because my guard was rubbing the judge's
knuckles just a slight bit that little
teeny tiny detail you live and you learn
well scott in one of our tightest
competitions to date you've become the
forest and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job
thank you thank you
i won baby yes
this ranks up there with getting married
having children oh yeah i'm a fortune
fire champion too by the way
what's next for me um get my 10 grand in
one so i can roll around in it you know
normal stuff you know what normal
champions do
you